Speaker 1: Hey, this is really, really
interesting. There's this channel called News,
Max. It's a crazy channel and they
have a host named Grant Stink Field.
And this guy went nuts when a veteran
went on and issued. It's like the mildest,
most milquetoast critique of Donald Trump.
The whole point was all of this terrible
stuff is happening in Afghanistan and it's Biden's
fault. And the the veterans simply tried to say,
hey, you know, it also like sort of would have
been Trump's thing, too. Like Trump had the same
plan. It was like the mildest critique and
grant stink field melts down, throws the guy
off and says you were not going to criticize
Trump on this channel. Whoa. Pretty serious
journalism. Hey, guys, let's take a look at this.
Speaker 2: I can tell you this. This didn't happen
under President Trump. And I know there's a lot
of people on the left that want to try to blame
President Trump. He wanted out of Afghanistan real
bad. He was real frustrated not being able to get
out, but he didn't pull out because he knew this
would happen. In fact, we all did. I called it on
this program. My 12 year old son knew about it.
And so I've got Americans there that are stuck.
To me, that's a hostage situation. But, Joe, I
appreciate you working to get them out. I really
do. And I wish you all due respect. Thank you.
With due respect, Grant, I mean, like veterans,
you know, being one right now, our friends are
over there. We follow this closely for multiple
administrations. And we know the administration's
efforts here were fairly weak. They were trying to
limit the number of people that would get out.
Speaker 1: This is like the mildest critique,
Speaker 2: risk coordination problems. I'm
going to go I'm going to cut you, I'm already
I'm already weak, I'm already low on time. Joe.
Joe, you cut him off, please. Cut him off now.
Come off now. You're not going to blame this on
President Trump on my show. No, it's not happening
now. I appreciate the work that you're doing. God
bless you for being a veteran. God bless you for
trying to get Americans out. But don't come on
this program and take the talking points to the
left and blame President Trump. That's not helping
anybody. The Biden administration screwed this
up from the very start. You know it. I know
what the country knows it and you call them
not hostages. I don't know how you don't call
them hostages. They're stuck in Afghanistan
with a country overrun with terrorists,
Speaker 1: guys out of his mind. I mean,
he's completely disconnected from reality
Speaker 2: that are willing to kill them all.
I'm mad about that man, I really am.
Speaker 1: How dare you question my
narrative veteran, but we support the
troops there. God bless. God bless.
Speaker 2: You can slow it down, please,
because we've got a real hero coming up,
that man's a real hero till we served
Speaker 1: before I get caught saying that that
veteran is not a hero. What happened to respecting
the troops? Right. I mean, that was you know, both
Speaker 2: of you both covered the trauma.
Speaker 1: Is that the White House and radio
out of nowhere, we have learned that support
the troops is support the mission of Republican
presidents. They don't really care about troops.
They don't really care about the opinion of
individuals if it conflicts with their view, if
it's not useful to their cause. And look at the
mental gymnastics that are going on there. He's
trying not to insult the troops. He even says
we're going to talk to a real hero next. But not
that that guy is not a hero, but we're not going
to allow it on this show. No, no, no, no, no.
God bless you. Except you're an ignorant leftist
sympathizer. But God bless you. I'm not saying
you're not a hero, but, you know, the next guy
is really a hero because he won't criticize Trump.
How this is not a skit is unbelievable. I mean,
this this this is a parody of this support the
troops ideology, support the troops. But this guy,
he criticized the Dear Leader. So all of a
sudden he is not a hero, but sort of but not
as much as the next guy that I'm going to bring
on. Incredible stuff happening over on Newsmax.
And it actually it's worth seeing it because it is
pushing the lines on hyper nationalism well beyond
Fox News. Very, very interesting. We'll have
more coverage of what took place there on our
Instagram. You can find us on Instagram at David
Pakman show. Find me on Instagram at David Pakman.